ce que si on regarde ici je pense que ça
arrive exactement on veut entre la salle
de bain à la buanderie victor d'avoine
vient tout juste de trouver son
appartement
après des mois de recherches et
d'occasions ratées il a acheté sur plan
dans villeray il se souvient encore des
condos qui lui ont échappé il ya un
appartement qu'on avait visité qu'on
aimait beaucoup
il y avait tout un line up devant
fallait attendre sa tournée à
l'intérieur donc il y avait vraiment
c'est un appartement chaud après avoir
vécu la même expérience à plusieurs
reprises il a fini par comprendre que
trouver un appartement était une
question de rapidité se met la pression
parce que peut décider vite surtout pour
un premier achat immobilier où on veut
être sûr de bien faire les choses
c'est un investissement financier on n'a
pas trop le temps de réfléchir
en 13 ans de métier sa courte hier
dominique chénier n'a jamais été aussi
débordés
en début d'année la propriété
apparaissent sur le marché et deux trois
jours après une journée après il ya déjà
des clients qui ont visité qui font des
offres on peut se retrouver avec une
offre deux offres 4 5 10 15
tout dépend bien sûr de l'état de la
propriété de son prix et du quartier et
les acheteurs sont prêts à tout pour
obtenir le condo souhaitait vendre la
sphère l'inspection a aussitôt des
copropriétés hochelaga-maisonneuve est
l'un des secteurs très prisé de montréal
où stocker un terme à un promoteur
arrive plus à construire des condos
c'est la course contre la montre et la
surenchère comme si on est affiché à 349
milles mais c'est un produit qui va
sortir facilement au-dessus du prix
affiché et ça peut aller jusqu'à 15000
un surenchère le marché fou j'ai
vraiment un marché pour les vendeurs
est-ce que c'est l'arrivée des
milléniaux en même temps que les
baby-boomers avant la retraite ça fait
tout des gens qui veulent pas s'occuper
d'une propriété donc le condo est une
solution
la réponse est oui en 2018 les ventes de
copropriétés ont affiché une hausse de
36% dans le sud-ouest de 13% dans
hochelaga-maisonneuve de 8% dans le
plateau mont royal
les ventes de condos ont littéralement
damer le pion à la somme des ventes de
plex de maisons pour enregistrer une
part de marché de 53 % sur l'île de
montréal
donc pour moi le c'est l'année de la
revanche du cours d'eau voici donc le
conseil que donne victor d'avoine aux
acheteurs bien cibler son quartier et
est prêt à prouver et être accompagné
par un portier et se dépêcher ici maxime
bertrand radio canada montréal